the way that he delivers his information
the people that actually could benefit
from a lot of things that he says are
women but they'll never be able to touch
it because the way it's communicated is
for men if his career was built on only
going on female podcasts explaining
these principles to them there's a
different version of Andrew Tate and it
might not make the views it's like even
with the episode that Pearl put out I
think the name of the episode is Tate
destroys feminist and I get it you're
tapping to the algorithm we all tap into
the algorithm the problem with that is
you're isolating the people that
actually would benefit from the message
through that algorithmic cocoon every
dude that just wants to see feminist
owns clicking that instead of a few
women they're like oh wait a minute is
that why my boyfriend or my husband
reacts with such insecurity when I do
that yeah oh and just because they do
doesn't make it right but at least you
know why they have that input